[Musica]
oggi nuova challenge con granny trova
gli slide nascosti da granny e oggi
avremo degli slime speciali praticamente
sarà come una caccia al tesoro
io dovrò riuscire a trovare tutti e 12 i
food sly e molestati granny mi prenda
per cinque volte quindi avrò comunque
cinque giorni di tempo però ne devo
recuperare 12 una volta che li ho
recuperati posso aprirli è vedere come
sono e gli slam che ho però sono gli
skifidol slime che sono dei nuovissimi
slime che sono usciti in edicola e sono
bellissimi
anche il packaging 15 sono tipo il
popcorn slime marshmallow quindi sono
novissimi slime non vedo l'ora di vedere
come sono
si chiamano food line perché sembra
tutto food ma ovviamente non si mangiano
solo degli sly li vedremo assieme se
riesco a trovarli tutti e dodici e forse
gremi riuscirà a prendermi prima figlio
riecco trovarli tutti e dodici senza che
i gremi mi prendo per cinque volte ho
vinto io la challenge training mi prende
per cinque volte prima che io li abbia
presi tutti e dodici ho perso la
challenge poi alla fine del video
dovrete iscrivervi nei commenti qual è
il vostro preferito dei dodici slime e
anch'io vi dirò qual è il mio preferito
siete pronti prendete i pop corn
mettetevi comodi e iniziamo subito la
challenge è la ricerca degli sly ecco
qua come potete vedere granny ha
lasciato la scatola vuota
hai ragione anche ha lasciato anche un
magazine che gentile comunque dopo
trovarli tutti iniziamo a cercare perché
potrebbero essere ovunque e voi nei
commenti si è riusciti ad avvistarli
prima di me scrivetemi dove sicuramente
se n'è anche qualcuno qua ma iniziamo ad
esplorare le altre stanze
[Musica]
vicino 13 passa ai ragazzi a prendere il
primo live e questo è il batter butters
line marshmallow non vedo l'ora di
aprirlo e viva questo è stato facile ma
non penso che gli altri un esisteranno
così facili apriamo le vediamo come ecco
qua dentro la scatolina c'era
quest'altra confezione dei rumors dello
slide sono soffici stime sembrano
proprio butters lime
il profumo è fantastico sono proprio di
marshmallow ora voglio mischiarli come
diventa bello è viva ho conquistato il
mio primo slide il mio marshmallows la
ora vediamo se riusciamo a trovare gli
altri e con berlino il mio piccolo
aiutante
ora proviamo a esplorare le altre stanze
e vino
ma partiamo
ecco trovato il grande slam con la bocca
granny mi ha beccato un giorno in meno
però sono riuscito a prendere il popcorn
cochran cdlive andiamo ad aprirlo
vediamo come dentro c'era questo slime
molto soffice che sembra tipo burro fuso
formaggio fuso e poi tipo giorno non so
perché occorre ovviamente altrimenti non
durerebbero molto lo slide sfigato ecco
fatto così diventa ecco qua
bellissimo anche questo tanto mal di
sottofondo se berlino che credo che il
suo ossicino anche questo è un profumo
fantastico che vive abbiamo già
recuperato due slime andiamo a cercare
gli altri due flame
andiamo a trovare gli altri merlino
major dissi mai a fare silenzio mentre
faccio questo talent niente sta
rosicchiando il suo vicino
[Musica]
credo che sarà possibile
l'abbiamo fatta giusto in tempo ho
trovato questo ho trovato questo fratti
grinta vediamolo subito allora in questa
slanci sono cari sono della barretta di
cioccolato miniatura canali e carine ci
sono dunque line
andiamo ad aprirmi subito vediamo come
solito ecco qua unito i due slime è un
bellissimo fluffy bianco oltre che
profuma di cioccolato e vaniglia e
stupendo
andiamo a mettere i pezzetti di
cioccolato
oddio che carino accaduta terrore è
stupendo questo finora è uno dei miei
preferiti vediamo se ne starà qualcun
altro che supererà questo andiamo
mischia li fa anche i suoni
scusate fan berlino continua a
rosicchiare noto è tutto fondo a checco
fatto ragazzi ho già tre slime è che
viva avere a cerchiamo gli altri non ho
cercato bene in questa stanza poi mi
avete visto qualcuno controllare bene se
sono nascosti in qualche angolino
controlliamo belli insieme allora quale
non mi sembra che ci sia niente neanche
qua c'è niente ma aspetta un momento che
se questa è una lattina è un cristiano e
non ha scosso là dentro
[Musica]
qui
1 credimi ha preso di nuovo perso un
altro giorno però almeno vostro voto 2
slam non uno ma due uno era nascosto
proprio davanti al mio libro è una era
nascosto dentro la tazza unicorno è il
viso ok andiamo ad aprire per primo il
nostro skifidol crystals lime soda
cremino con per proprio una lattina da
corsi skeet
ecco qua ragazzo anche questo è enorme
queste più uno slam trasparente che sa
punto di cola anche se mi sembra di
sentire un motore dolce bellissimo anche
questo devo dire che questa volta si
possono proprio superati
sentiamo i suoni
[Musica]
prossimo che i geni slime strawberry
chiediamo apriamolo carine ci sono delle
fragoline retrofit e ovviamente questo
un profumo di fragola fantastico
trasparente questo è più sul rosso e
alle fragoline dentro cordate berlino
anche lui e super interessante che cairo
voglio prendere una fragolina vedere
com'è fatta bormida
pensavo fosse dura la fragolina invece
morbide squillo sapendo anche questo ok
ragazzi ho recuperato 5 slime me ne
mancano ancora un po però e ho solo due
giorni o tre giorni
non mi ricordo che spunti crimi
all'improvviso
[Musica]
mamma
quanto mostrano su pescara e si chiama g
sì che di frequente voglio provare a
continuare andare avanti per
qualcos'altro qua e di là dietro che
sono sicuro c'è qualcosa qui mi sembra
che ci sia niente forse meglio scappa
[Musica]
aspetta che cos'è questa cosa ci sta
guardate la sopra ce n'è uno ragione
troppo pericoloso perché sono un altro
c'era uno slam arancione ma premierà la
dieta ed era troppo pericoloso non posso
sprecare un altro giorno però almeno
sono riuscite a prendere questi due
apriamoli subito video come sono che il
primo che abbiamo trovato è questo slam
skifidol khamis
vediamo un po come eccolo qua il colore
è stupendo sapete che io d'oro di
celeste e lo stesso mousseline
trasparente e al tipo queste perline
ciambelline dentro il profumo e di
caramella ora vediamo il flap shooters
line booking di maigret ecco qua dentro
c'erano due live anche qua tipo delle
perline colorate simo di caramello e
queste perline colorate dentro sono
super carine vediamo un po quanto il
flat e questo slime è molto simile a
quello al fluffy di prima chocolate però
è rosa ea queste termini e dentro invece
ci mancano solo 5 slime forse possiamo
farcela ragazzi anche se ora si fa
ancora più tipici
mi stava cercando
per fortuna non mi ha trovato perché
sono nascosta dietro la porta
dobbiamo stare su prendenti berlino
aiutami diventi perfino gli sbadigli
sempre mi deve fare merlino e colori
[Musica]
guardate
si no io ho preso due che questa volta
[Musica]
wow
non credi mia prezzo di nuovo e che se
ho preso due slime questo è il mio
ultimo giorno aiutami tu dumbo aiutami a
trovare gli slime di invii dove sono
zumbo aiutavi ma dumbo
che cos'è questo sempre grandi lo ha
messo li faccio un uso accorgermene
e un altro quindi me ne mancano solo due
anche se non ho idea di dove siano
perché non li ho visti da nessuna parte
quindi saranno sicuramente i più
difficili di avuto più di tutti vediamo
come sono
ecco quello che ho trovato adesso e lo
skifidol slime lemon jelly quindi spera
di limone limonata tipo viviamo nobel
questo è fantastico perché è fatto tipo
molte slime essendo appunto stile
limonata oltre ad avere dei piccoli
piccoli morsi vetro fettine di limone e
tifo water sly un nuovo fantastico e poi
super trasparente se volesse di vedere
se ce ne saranno altri tipo waters line
come questo il profumo ovviamente e giù
per li monouso
ora vediamo gli altri questo è lo slam
fluffy caniglia fragrance sembra che
hanno fatto tipo la bottiglietta del
latte è infatti che abbia uno slide
bianco che so di vaniglia
ed è la fine di un po eccolo qua un
carinissimo anche questo
[Musica]
e ora crediamo lo slam orancelli questo
penso che sia un'aranciata visto che
l'inter l'altra era tipo una limonata
vediamo se anche questo ha una
consistenza un water mi sembra proprio
di sì oddio che cari io adoro le cose in
miniatura non s'era capito questo tipo
uno spicchio di arancio mondo rino ed è
qui sodo anche questo è morbido e lo
slime e walker slime come quello la
limonata non va bene
fantastico e proprio carino che i
ragazzi dobbiamo recuperare solo due
però dobbiamo stare super attenti quindi
da ora mi raccomando silenzio con calma
andiamo
cerchiamo di prenderli senza essere
beccati da che abbiamo
[Musica]
k mila sconvolti
chissà quando
[Musica]
credi si è spaventata di se stessa lo
spicchio di è colpita da sola o in un po
sconvolto possa scioccato anche tu
[Musica]
tutto il penultimo slime il butters line
cream ora ne manca solo uno
un idea di dove possa essere dobbiamo
guardare bene forse non è in questa
stanza
[Musica]
meno preso uno slam
trovate tutti
[Musica]
ultimo giorno sono non ho ancora perso
ha quindi conta anche il quinto giorno
per fortuna non ho perso e comparato gli
ultimi due games
mi basta solo aprirli ora è vedere come
sono
no non puoi farmi niente io eccoli qua e
qua
eccoli coni comparato tutti a 12 bit
line abbiamo vinto la challenge
ora non ci resta che vedere come sono
questi due slime e scegliamo quello che
ci piace di più siete pronti andiamo ad
aprirli perché abbiamo alla fine
innanzitutto l'orange slime grammi per
un po anche questo nella finta la spina
ecco allora che ami slime ha un
buonissimo profumo di arancia e anche
questo è uno slam con trasparente e
tutti che è enorme anche questo sentiamo
[Musica]
ecco qua l'ultimo slime il butterfly
kring cioccolata per curiosare qua è un
bellissimo battere sofficissimo e il
profumo meraviglioso sa proprio di
nocciola cioccolato e morbidi
come vedete come si spalma un batter
fantastico non so quale scegliere come
preferito perché mi sono piaciuti tutti
anche questo è fantastico guardate
quante grande enorme che questo allora
il mio preferito è difficile da
scegliere mi è piaciuto tantissimo la
limonata perché waters ha un profumo di
limone che io adoro i limoni questo poi
mi è piaciuto tantissimo questo con i
mini cioccolati carinissimi e poi
dainese l'ultimo l'ultimo detto perché
non super butter super morbido quindi
questi sono i miei tre preferiti in un
rischio sceglierne solo uno
scrivetemi voi nei commenti qual è il
vostro preferito o i vostri preferiti e
io vi ricordo che potete trovare gli
skifidol food line in edicola a 3 euro e
50 l'uno in allegato al magazine
officina team mi raccomando chiedete
sempre il magazine
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri silence credi e ora vi
lascio fa quattro cartellini sto per
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
che carte su quella che preferite e la
leggerezza